La Nouvelle-Orléans peut être une ville difficile à mourir
dans les monstres que vous lisez quand vous étiez enfant,
ils sont réels et ils sont ici des loups-garous des
vampires ils se cachent partout en
survivant en s'assurant qu'aucun de nous ne
sache qu'ils sont ici où d'autre pourriez-vous vous
cacher  si vous êtes une créature de la nuit,
il y avait un pacte entre tous les morts-vivants
pour désigner un seul humain comme
inspecteur impartial un enquêteur l'un de leurs
propres lignes franchies, il m'appelle Dylan chien
apparemment les loups de Port Authority
mais quand c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
apporté  de l'ancien pays les lignes
sont franchies un peu finissent par déclencher une
guerre le cœur cela s'appelle une insuffisance cardiaque
il y a 5 000 ans il a acheté un jeu artisanal
créé par le ventre de pot j'ai parlé d'une guerre ce
sera ici dans les rues et ce sera
sanglant
alors quel est le plan
juste des armes plus grosses